j'ai rencontré jean peu de temps après
la mort de mon père j'étais un jeune
écrivain et une nuits font cette tête
décident dans la société
il venait d'épouser une nana de 16 ans
qui s'appelait marie lou qui trouve que
c'est déjà fabuleux
j'en ai jamais rencontré des comme ça je
dois bien ça j'en suis mon exemple
avec dean moriarty a commencé la partie
de ma vie qu'on pourrait appeler la vie
sur la route s'était enfin décidé à
fournir
ce sans aucune aide pour sabilité envers
ses congénères
il suffit d'être lui-même pour donner du
plaisir une désillusion
c'est un escroc soit qui s'en remettra
c'est quelque chose qui cloche
on fait tous ces trucs stupides j'ai des
idées tordues tout le temps
je brûle tu comprends mieux
[Musique]
et je les ai suivis en traînant les
pieds comme j'ai toujours fait qu'en
raison d'intérêts
parce que les seuls qui m'intéresse ce
sont les fous furieux et
ceux qui ont la fureur de vivre la
ferveur de dire ce qu'ils veulent toi
même temps ce qui ne va jamais ne
profère jamais banal
et qui en une
d
[Musique]
et